امام جمعيه الشبان المسيحيه في شارع
الجلاء وسط مدينه غزه هذا المبنى الذي تم
تدميره بالكامل ودخلت قوات الاحتلال له
ايضا وكانت هناك العديد من العائلات
المحاصره داخل
الجمعيه القذائف سقطت في كل مكان داخل
الجمعيه المواطنون الان يقومون بدفن
شهدائهم داخل جمعيه الشبان
المسيحيه
يقومون الان بدفن الشهداء الذين سقطوا
داخل جمعيه
الشبان
المسيحيه العديد من الشهداء تم دفنهم داخل
الجمعيه كنا مدنين مدين قاعدين مركز الواج
ع مسيحيه وص صار طخطخ علينا عننا ثمان
شهدات وفي منا جرحه
مصابين ما ح عننا في حد ل في علاقه لا في
هذا ولا في هذا قاعدين نازحين كنا مدينين
كما نرى امامنا مقبره جماعيه للشهداء داخل
جمعيه الشبان المسيحيه بعد ان تم قصفها من
قبل قوات الاحتلال والعائلات كانت نازحه
في داخلها نتحدث عن احراق جميع الغرف
وسقوط القذائف داخل الغرف قصف الطوابق
العلويه ايضا والدمار كبير داخل
الجمعيه